[Music]
hello there watching the press preview a
first look at what is on the front pages
time then to see what is making the
headlines with the observer's chief
leader writer sonia soder and the chief
executive of conservative home mark
wallace both of them with us until just
before midnight welcome to both of you
so to the front pages then let us start
with the guardian it quotes president
joe biden insisting that the leaked
decision from the u.s supreme court
which looks set to overturn women's
nationwide access to abortions imperils
civil rights
bp's first quarter earnings of six
billion dollars are prompting fresh
calls for a winful tax to be imposed on
the oil giant with the aim of helping
the public pay their energy bills that
is according to the financial times
the merit questions whether the pm will
step in on the rising cost of living
saying the situation was beyond pathetic
the metro reports that a man has
appeared in court charged with funneling
government loans intended to help his
business during the pandemic to a group
of islamic state fighters in syria
the telegraph hears that senior mps are
demanding that the french government
reveals what it knows about the use of
exocept missiles which killed dozens of
british sailors during the falklands war
the man who can't answer a straight
question the daily mail takes aim at kia
stammer over beergate
quick reminder that by scanning the qr
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us so let's bring in our guest
then sonia soda and mark wallace um we
call it a mixed bag don't we when
everything's got a different headline
but let's start with the guardian shall
we sonia
and this leaked report i mean
unprecedented to have a leak from the
u.s supreme court um of this opinion
decision effectively but it's caused
quite a stir because of the implications
on abortion and other rights in fact
yes that's right so the way it works in
the supreme court is that there are
drafts of judgments that will go round
before the supreme court publishes its
final judgment and makes it public and
what we what's been leaked to the press
in the u.s is one of those drafts which
very much makes it look like the supreme
court may be about to in the coming
months overturn roe v wade and for uh
viewers who aren't aware of what ray v
wade is it's a really landmark piece of
legislation uh of
it's a landmark court ruling from the
united states in the 1970s that
essentially made abortion legal
throughout the us and it kind of acts as
a guarantee of women's reproductive
rights across the states there are a
small number of states that want to
to make abortion illegal or to make it
incredibly restrictive and roe v wade
has acted as a safety net um to stop uh
state governments doing that now i think
this is incredibly worrying um because
we know what happens when abortion gets
severely restricted to women well it
doesn't lower the abortion rate what
happens is that women try and do it
themselves and um they you know many
women will end up losing their lives or
doing themselves great harm so whether
or not you believe in the philosophical
case for uh choice when it comes to
women's reproductive rights and i very
much do because a woman's body is her
own and she should not be forced to go
through with a pregnancy that she
doesn't want there is also a pragmatic
case which is it doesn't stop abortion
to make it illegal it just means that
you get very dangerous backstreet
abortions so this is incredibly worrying
for women's rights in the us i think it
shows the extent to which you know we've
got a very settled consensus here in the
uk now really which is that abortion
must be legal women must be able to
access it whereas in the us where things
are much more polarized there is a
fundamentalist religious right which has
sought to roll back these very important
rights for women and i think that's what
we're seeing and i think it's important
to say
you know this goes against the grain of
public opinion as well there is
definitely a significant majority in the
us
in favor of abortion yes i think senator
warren suggested it was 69 of of women
certainly didn't want to see it but we
saw protests did we not at the u.s
supreme court today from both sides uh
and you know mark we always knew this
that one of the biggest impacts of the
trump presidency was what happened to
the makeup of the us supreme court and
here we are seeing one of the first
consequences
potentially yes obviously the supreme
court themselves are are arguing in this
unusual
very very rare kind of leaked situation
that drafts don't equate final
conclusions etc but you know this is a
bit of a cautionary tale i think for
this country we often have um kind of
broad sweeping comments that wouldn't it
be great and much simpler if we had a
written constitution a purely written
constitution
in a binding sense in the united kingdom
when sometimes our own parliamentary
system is a bit messy um
to put it mildly but this is a
cautionary tell sonia um a couple of
minutes ago uh almost said that roe v
wade was a change in the law and
committed herself correctly you know
rightly to say that it was a a court
verdict
peculiarly i don't think it's just about
polarization of politics or polarization
of society in the united states
which has made this such a an ongoing
difficult painful issue in their
politics it's partially because this
whole thing was settled in the 1970s
through a supreme court verdict based on
a constitutional amendment passed in the
1860s
rather than going down the upfront
political way of politicians being big
enough and brave enough and bold enough
and clear enough to make a decision and
to legislate um it's undoubtedly the
case as sonia says that um the the
american public opinion is not in favor
of um uh rolling back these rights of
restricting
women's reproductive rights in the way
that a verdict like this would happen
would would may happen um
but we've ended they've ended up with
this ludicrous position really where you
have a
part of the constitution that doesn't
seem to have necessarily been written
with this aspect of law entirely in mind
a supreme court a century later making
decisions and then threatening to go
back on them back and forth there's no
way to establish basic rights like this
it should be something done through
legislation through politics politicians
being bold enough to change the law for
the things that they believe to be right
yes we're certainly keeping on what
happens with that uh won't we but let's
move on to the prospect or not of a
windfall tax this is front page of the
financial times uh prompted by the
highest quarterly earnings for bp in
more than a decade uh thanks to of
course soaring prices for oil and gas um
you know partly because what we're
seeing in russia and ukraine sonia
that's right um uh so they're they're
sort of making record um earnings which
i think does rather shore up labour's
arguments for a windfall tax on the
energy companies now obviously the rural
price of energy is going up the royal
price of oil is going up and that's
partly because of the ukraine war
although that was already happening um
before russia launched its latest
invasion of ukraine
um but i think it's important to
remember that even as the raw costs of
materials go up we often see oil
companies um energy companies actually
make
very high levels of profit
and what we need to be careful doesn't
happen is that rising prices are not
used as a bit of a screen
for companies also kind of uh
you know making record earnings and
paying out those earnings to
shareholders rather than reinvesting
them in the energy system
many shareholders are
pension funds for those lucky enough to
have pensions and the chief executive
bernard looney did say it's just 15
months since bp recorded its largest
loss because of low oil prices he talks
about volatility and also marked the
need to invest both in the north sea is
this idea of transition transition fuels
um but also in things like charging
points at all their service stations for
electric vehicles so where do where do
you sit in this argument
well
indeed it's important to bear those
things in mind sony is right of course
to say that you must always be watchful
against um undue and unfair price
gouging there's a story in the on the
front page of the telegraph i think with
the business secretary warning against
uh any suggestion of uh you know there's
allegations of manipulation of debit
calculations and so on you should always
be careful
to
uh to to guard against things like that
but let's also look at what it is well
all we've all spent the last three
months two months saying we wanted the
energy system we want these companies to
divest themselves of
operations in russia i think i'm right
in saying that bb has
said that it's going to do that
effectively abandoning um a massive
investment and oil
gas field that has in russia for obvious
reasons that russia is now a pariah
tyranny um we're also saying we want to
rebuild the energy system so it's not so
reliant on imports from
russia but also from from other
tyrannies like saudi arabia for example
at the same time everybody's saying they
want these big investments um to pursue
uh for example net zero the
electrification of
cars and so on and so forth if you want
to do all those things and have those
pension funds and so on you mentioned
actually able to reap the money they
need for people's retirement what you
cannot start doing is just standing up
one day and saying i'm the government
and what i'm going to do is i'm going to
batter um companies uh with with
arbitrary one-off windfall taxes things
like that don't just
have an immediate cash impact they have
a long-term investment impact and they
really affect the stability of
the reputation for stability of an
economy of somewhere to invest in things
like infrastructure and that's really
what we need on the energy front
okay both of you uh there were plenty
more things to talk about but i'm afraid
we don't have time for that section
because there's loads more to pack in
including we continue to take a first
look at tomorrow's newspapers in the
press preview including this on the
front of the times their headline
privately educated to lose places at
oxbridge that in just a moment
[Music]
well welcome back you're watching the
press preview with me now the observer's
chief leader writer sonia soder and the
chief executive of conservative home
mark wallace welcome back to both of you
and mark we're going to go to the
telegraph now which is a a story that
dates back decades could you just
explain to us what what what this is all
about
well in brief it's a fascinating story
this is part of the um 40th anniversary
coverage of the falklands war and um a
lot of people who uh were watching uh
and reading about that story at the time
uh will remember the role played by
exocept missiles these are missiles that
the argentinians had bought from france
um they were cutting edge technology
they hit three royal navy ships and um
and caused the deaths of several dozen
british
service personnel and what's really
interesting is there's this allegation
there's a rumor at the time now more
suggestions and demands for it to be
clarified by france that there was a
kill switch inside these missiles that
france had made them so that if they
fell into the wrong hands and were fired
at french ships that there was a kind of
signal you could send that would switch
them off would make them fall harmlessly
into the sea and that france refused or
failed to disclose those to britain its
ally at the time of the war and there's
understandably mps are now asking yet
again for some for for you know the
eliza palace to come clean as to what
was or was not known or what was or was
not done
okay and uh front page of the times now
sonia um the privately educated must
accept they will not gain as many places
at oxford and cambridge in fact other
leading universities too uh this is
according to the vice chancellor of
cambridge
yes uh so it's a very interesting
intervention from professor stephen tupe
who is the vice chancellor there and
what he's saying is that over time the
private school advantage um in oxbridge
will erode i think that's quite right
too so private school students are
really quite over-represented at
oxbridge
um you know oxbridge is a university
where there are actually more teaching
resources
put in
and i think it's really important
actually that these universities are
open to everyone um you know all bright
kids from all backgrounds and the thing
is that we know
that you know that
very bright kids from poor backgrounds
they tend to fall behind academically at
school not because they're not bright
but because they have
less educational opportunities and
advantages than kids from more
advantaged backgrounds and to me that
means that you know a kid from a very
working-class background who gets
perhaps an a into b that's sometimes a
bigger achievement
than someone who went to a private
school and who um you know had very
intensive tuition and support in the
build up to exam
and got all a's so i think it's actually
really really important that
universities take a more flexible
approach on this sonia soda mark wallace
thank you both very much indeed thank
you